This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The holiday season is a time of giving to our friends and loved ones, but also the strangers in the form of donations or charity. On this week's episode, we'll explore the psychology of giving. We'll look at what motivates us to give to charities. Once they see that there's a solicitor at the door, they say, oh my god, I wish I would have stayed on the couch watching the football game. Why it's okay to be a regifter and why sometimes, lying to small children can be a gift.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。假日季是一个向朋友和挚爱送出礼物，同时也通过捐款或慈善向陌生人献爱心的时期。在这一期的节目中，我们将探讨给予的心理学。我们将探讨是什么激励我们向慈善机构捐款。一旦他们看到门口有个募捐员，他们就会想，天哪，我真希望当时一直瘫在沙发上看橄榄球赛。为什么转送礼物并没有什么问题，以及为什么有时对小孩子撒谎也可以算是一种礼物。
Fair point, but I just think you've totally lost our 8 and under-demo-grabber. Finally, well-known philanthropist Adam Cole is back, he's going to give us the gift of music and tie the episode together with a song. Inspired by those really cheesy Christmas specials in which children dance around in brightly colored sweaters. Lots of fast-make charitable donations over the holiday season, maybe you write a few checks, maybe you donate online, or maybe you get asked directly at a shopping mall or the grocery store. But what motivates you to give and is a change with the situation?
很有道理，但我只是觉得你完全把我们8岁及以下的观众群体给弄丢了。最后，知名慈善家亚当·科尔又回来了，他将为我们带来音乐的礼物，并用一首歌将本期节目串联起来。灵感来自于那些穿着色彩鲜艳毛衣的孩子们四处跳舞的、非常俗气的圣诞特辑。在假日季期间有许多快速的慈善捐款，也许你开几张支票，也许你在网上捐款，或者你可能会在购物中心或杂货店被直接要求捐款。但究竟是什么驱使你慷慨解囊？情况的变化又会带来什么影响呢？
One of our producers Maggie Pennman and our news assistant Max Nestrak went to investigate. So Max and I went to the Giant in Silver Spring, Maryland. It's a big suburban grocery store, very busy on a Saturday afternoon, but we came not to shop, but for another reason. Right, we waited in front of the Salvation Army collection. We met a nice woman there named Lisa Ingram with a Santa hat on that said naughty. to shop, but for another reason. Right, we waited in front of the Salvation Army collection. We met a nice woman there named Lisa Ingram with a Santa hat on that said naughty. She was ringing her bell and people were dropping in their loose change, a few dollar bills.
我们的制作人之一玛吉·彭曼和我们的新闻助理马克斯·内斯特拉克前去进行了调查。因此，马克斯和我去了马里兰州银泉市的Giant超市。那是一家大型郊区杂货店，在周六下午非常忙碌，但我们来不是为了购物，而是为了另一个原因。没错，我们在救世军的募捐箱前等候。我们在那儿遇到了一位穿着写有“淘气”字样的圣诞老人帽子的好心女士，名叫丽莎·英格拉姆。来不是为了购物，而是为了另一个原因。没错，我们在救世军的募捐箱前等候。我们在那儿遇到了一位穿着写有“淘气”字样的圣诞老人帽子的好心女士，名叫丽莎·英格拉姆。她一直在摇铃，人们则把零钱和几张纸币投进箱子里。
I saw someone put a tent in. We really wanted to know why. And the first person we talked to was Charles J. Barber Jr. He seemed like a really popular guy, even in our very short interview, he kept getting interrupted by his friends walking by. But hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, how you doing? But he said for him it's about being able to empathize with people who are in need. Some of us are just stones throw away from, you know, being, you know, in a bad place
我看到有人投了一张二十美元。我们真的很想知道原因。我们采访的第一个人是小查尔斯·J·巴贝尔。他似乎是个非常受欢迎的人，甚至在我们非常短暂的采访中，他也不断被路过的情感。有些人的处境，你知道的，距离落魄
too, so hopefully this helps people who need it. Next, there was Jarell Bactin. I mean, it was actually a change that Iin. I mean, it was extra change that I had. I mean, every little bit counts. And I mean, I mean, every penny counts, whatever you can do, is just be able to reach out and help. Stella Lore was at the store with a friend. She bought me some tea that cost almost $4 or so.
也只有一步之遥，所以希望这能帮助到需要它的人。接下来是贾雷尔·巴克廷。我的意思是，这其实是我身上多出来的零钱。我的意思是，积少成多。我的意思是，一分钱也是爱，无论你能做什么，只要能伸出援手去帮助别人。斯特拉·洛尔和朋友一起去了商店。她给我买了一些茶，花了我差不多4美元左右。
I said, well, I'd just say $4. Pay it forward. Exactly. So I'm just going to pay it forward. Next, we talked to Lee Sheniger. Well, I just give in general, and he had a loose change, so believe that. Does it make you feel good when you give? Oh, I suppose so.
我说，好吧，就当是4美元吧。把爱传递下去。没错。所以我只是把爱传递下去。接下来，我们采访了李·舍尼格。嗯，我只是随缘捐点，他刚好有零钱，所以就信了这个。捐款会让你感觉良好吗？哦，我想是的。
And finally, we talked to Bonnie Scott. So, why did you put a dollar in the bucket? Well, I like to see people being helped. So why not give them a dollar when I see them? Do you give every time you see the Salvation Army bucket? Yes, I'm guilty. And why do you think you always have to, like, every time you go to a store around this time of year,
最后，我们采访了邦妮·斯科特。那么，你为什么要在桶里放一美元呢？嗯，我喜欢看到别人得到帮助。所以当我看到他们时，为什么不给他们一美元呢？每次看到救世军的募捐桶你都会捐款吗？是的，我有罪恶感。那你觉得为什么每次一年中的这个时候去商店，
why do you feel like you have to give a dollar? People need right now. So why not? So there you have it, Chunker. People give because they want to help. Because it makes them feel good. And because they want to pay it forward. That was Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak,
你都觉得必须捐出一美元呢？人们现在需要帮助。所以为什么不呢？所以事情就是这样，尚卡尔。人们捐款是因为他们想帮忙。因为这让他们感觉良好。并且因为他们想将这份善意传递下去。那是玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克，
with a lot of very sweet people at the grocery store, showing us the positive side of generosity. But there's also a more cynical take. And that was summarized in a recent episode of South Park where Stan's dad, Randy Marsh, gets pressured to donate a dollar at the checkout line at a very socially conscious Whole Foods. Okay, Sarah, looks like your total is 37.83. Alright, okay, and would you like to add a dollar donation to help hungry kids around
杂货店里有很多非常可爱的人，向我们展示了慷慨善良的一面。但也有人持有更偏向讽刺的观点。这一点在《南方公园》最近的一集里得到了概括，其中斯坦的父亲兰迪·马什在一家极具社会意识的全食超市的结账处被迫捐出一美元。好的，莎拉，看来你的总计是37.83美元。好的，那么你想加一美元的捐款来帮助全世界挨饿的
the world? Oh, uh, no, that's okay. Sorry? I'm good. I'm sorry, you don't want to give the dollar to hungry kids? Not today, thank you. Okay, no problem. Windows gonna come up and ask if you're helping the hungry kids just hit no I'm not.
儿童吗？哦，呃，不用了，没关系。抱歉？我不用了。不好意思，你不想把那一美元捐给挨饿的孩子吗？今天不用了，谢谢。好的，没问题。一会儿屏幕会弹出来问你是否要帮助饥饿的儿童，只要点“我不想”。
Oh come on. Try hitting it again. It's the box below the one that says sure I'd love to help however I can. Ah darn thing, sorry. Most people give the dollar. I can do this manually. Look, I give money to charity a lot, okay? Oh, sure you do. I do. I just don't want to every time I shop for food.
哦，拜托。再试着点一下。就是写着“当然，我很乐意尽我所能提供帮助”下面那个方框。啊，该死的，抱歉。大多数人都给那一美元。我可以手动操作。听着，我经常向慈善机构捐款，好吗？哦，当然，你捐了。我捐了。我只是不想每次买食物时都捐。
That's completely understandable. Have customers speak, I'm at- Oh, okay. If you can just speak into the voice to Coder and say, I'm not giving anything to the hungry kids. I'm not giving anything to the hungry kids. So which version of generosity is right? The positive, life-affirming people that Maggie and Max talked with? Or the guilt-trip philanthropist at the checkout line?
这完全可以理解。让顾客来说，我-哦，好吧。如果你能对着语音编码器说，“我不会给饥饿的孩子任何东西”。我不会给饥饿的孩子任何东西。那么，哪一种版本的慷慨才是正确的呢？是玛吉和马克斯交谈过的那些积极向上、肯定生命的人？还是结账时进行道德绑架的慈善家？
I recently had a conversation about this with all things considered host Audi Cornish. We talked about why the reasons you think you give may not actually be the real reason. So this is the time of years I say when people are perceived as being more charitable, but is it all altruistic? Well when you ask people why they are generous, they will tell you that it is all about altruism, that they love a cause or they like to give. But scientists have increasingly sought to test these claims, Adi. I spoke with the economist John List, he's at the University of Chicago.
我最近和《万事皆议》的主持人奥迪·科尼什就此进行了对话。我们讨论了为什么你认为自己慷慨解囊的原因可能并不是真正的动机。所以可以说，这就是一年中人们被认为更有爱心的时期，但这一切都是无私的吗？嗯，当你问人们为什么慷慨时，他们会告诉你这一切都是出于无私，他们热爱某个事业或者他们喜欢给予。但科学家们越来越多地试图检验这些说法，奥迪。我采访了芝加哥大学的经济学家约翰·利斯特。
He's conducted a number of experiments into why people give, and he explained to me why he thinks this is important to do. Anytime you ask someone, why did you give to this charitable cause, the typical response is, I gave because I really want to help another person. But when you actually dig down deeper, that's not the true motive for why they gave, and that's exactly why we need field experiments to try to disentangle reasons why people give. And I understand, Tucker, one of the reasons may be social pressure, right? And he does some experiments to try and make that case. That's right. So, this thinks that social pressure might be playing a very powerful role.
他做了许多关于人们为什么捐赠的实验，他向我解释了他为什么认为这样做很重要。每当你问某人，你为什么要向这个慈善事业捐款时，典型的回答是，我捐款是因为我真的很想帮助另一个人。但当你真正深入挖掘时，这并不是他们捐款的真实动机，而这正是我们需要现场实验来试图厘清人们捐赠原因的原因。我明白，尚卡尔，原因之一可能是社会压力，对吧？他做了一些实验来试图证明这一点。没错。所以，利斯特认为社会压力可能发挥了非常强大的作用。
And he asks me to think about a scenario that's going to be familiar to lots of us. Here he is again. You're sitting on the couch watching a football game. And you hear somebody knocking on the door. And you think, okay, should I get up or should I stay watching the football game? Of course, a lot of people get up and answer the door. But once they see that there's a solicitor at the door,
他让我去想一个我们许多人都很熟悉的场景。他再次这样说道。你正坐在沙发上看一场橄榄球赛。然后你听到有人在敲门。你心想，好吧，我是该起来开门呢，还是继续看橄榄球赛？当然，很多人会起身去应门。但一旦他们看到门口站着一个募捐员，
they say, oh my God, I wish I would have stayed on the couch watching the football game. Right, so basically you feel like you've been put on the spot. Exactly, and Lists realized that this scenario provides the perfect mechanism for an experiment that tries to find out how much social pressure plays a role in altruism. Lists sent volunteers into various Chicago neighborhoods to solicit money for a children's hospital, but there was a catch-oddie. Some households just got a cold call, a knock on the door.
他们就会想：天哪，我真希望自己当时留在沙发上看橄榄球赛就好了。没错，基本上就是觉得被架在火上烤了。完全如此，利斯特意识到，这种场景为一项实验提供了完美的机制，该实验旨在探究社会压力在利他主义中发挥了多大作用。利斯特派志愿者前往芝加哥的各个社区为一家儿童医院募捐，但有个附加条件，奥迪。有些住户只是接到突击拜访，也就是敲门。
Others were alerted ahead of time that someone was going to be knocking on their door and asking for money. A third group was told that the knock was coming and given the choice to opt out, they could say they didn't want to be disturbed. Now if people were giving only because of altruism, it shouldn't matter whether they know ahead of time that a knock is coming, but list finds that when households are alerted ahead of time, the number of people who answer that knock on the door, it falls by a quarter. When people are given the choice to opt out and say they don't want to be disturbed,
另一些住户则提前得到了通知，知道有人会来敲门并索要捐款。第三组被告知会有敲门声，并且可以选择退出，他们可以表明自己不想被打扰。如果人们捐款仅仅是出于利他主义，那么他们是否提前知道会有敲门声应该并不重要，但利斯特发现，当住户提前接到通知时，开门应门的人数下降了四分之一。当人们被赋予选择退出的权利并表示他们不想被打扰时，
donations fall by nearly half. And what list says to shows is how much social pressure shapes generosity. What you find is that roughly three quarters of the dollars given are due to social pressure and a quarter of the dollars given is actually due to altruism now of course already we should mention that this was one experiment and one setting
捐款额下降了近一半。利斯特的研究表明，社会压力在多大程度上塑造了慷慨。你发现大约四分之三的捐款是由于社会压力，而四分之一的捐款实际上是由于利他主义，当然，奥迪，我们应该提到这只是一项实验和一种情境，
the lots of other reasons why people might want to give people write checks in the privacy of their own homes where there's no social pressure but in this kind of situation and there many like it you know you you encounter somebody at the door of uh... store as you're leaving or maybe you're at church and people are passing the collection play, it's situations like that where social pressure probably plays an enormous role. So the idea that you're basically uncomfortable saying no to someone's face, right? Exactly, so in this experiment you don't want the person at the door to think that you're
人们想要捐款的原因还有很多，人们在自己私密的家中开具支票，那里没有社会压力，但在这类情境中，而且有许多类似的情境，你知道的，你在离开商店时在门口遇到某人，或者也许你在教堂里，人们正在传递募捐盘，正是在这种情境下，社会压力可能发挥了巨大的作用。所以这种观点基本上就是你很难当面拒绝别人，对吧？没错，所以在这次实验中，你不想让门口的人认为你
a jerk for not wanting to help a children's hospital. The dilemma already is that for charities, putting people on the spot is effective, but it might be effective only in the short term because people don't like to be pressured and they're going to find ways to dodge it. List in fact believes that charities need to focus on the 25% of people who are genuinely motivated by altruism because this is the group of people who are likely to be your long-term supporters. So what are some of the other strategies that charities and others have found to get us to open our wallets?
是个不想帮助儿童医院的混蛋。奥迪，两难的困境在于，对慈善机构而言，把人架在火上烤很有效，但它可能只在短期内有效，因为人们不喜欢被施压，他们会想方设法躲避。事实上，利斯特认为慈善机构需要关注那25%真正由利他主义驱使的人，因为这群人很可能成为你的长期支持者。那么，慈善机构和其他机构为了让我们打开钱包，还发现了哪些其他策略呢？
You know, are there literally dozens of different things that people have tried? One of them is that when a charity sends you a gift, maybe they send you a calendar, the norm of reciprocity dictates that you send something back to them in exchange. Another idea is that if you can get people to donate their time to a cause, they're more likely to follow up with donations because people's wallets follow their feet. So I'm feeling a little guilty now for my introduction, right? The norms of the holiday season, right? This is the time of year to give. Does that also create a form of social pressure? You can think about social norms exactly as a larger example of social pressure at work.
你知道，人们尝试的方法简直有几十种之多吗？其中之一就是，当慈善机构给你寄礼物时，也许他们给你寄一本挂历，礼尚往来的规范决定了你也应该回赠他们一些东西。另一个想法是，如果你能让人们为某项事业捐出他们的时间，他们更有可能进行后续捐款，因为人们的钱包总是追随着他们的脚步。所以现在我的开场白让我感到有点内疚，对吧？假日季的规范，对吧？这是一年中送礼物的季节。这也会产生一种社会压力吗？你可以把社会规范看作是社会压力在现实中一个更大范围的例子。
If you're at a workplace and everyone's writing checks to charities or doing things that are charitable, you feel kind of obliged to do the same. Shankar, thanks so much for explaining it. Thank you so much, Arty. After the short break, Dan Pink is back for another round of stop-what science. We'll give you some tips on how to be more generous and give better gifts. We'll also tell you about the downside of altruism. After this. Welcome back. We have more ideas about charity and gift giving in our next stopwatch science segment.
如果你在工作场所，每个人都在给慈善机构开支票或者做慈善活动，你就会觉得有义务也这样做。尚卡尔，非常感谢你的解释。非常感谢你，奥迪。短暂休息之后，丹·皮克将携另一轮“暂停科学”环节回归。我们将为您提供一些关于如何更加慷慨和赠送更好礼物的建议。我们还将告诉您利他主义的阴暗面。广告之后见。欢迎回来。在我们的下一个“暂停科学”环节中，我们有更多关于慈善和送礼的想法。
I'm joined as usual by Senior Stopwatch science correspondent Daniel Pink. Hi, Dan. Hey, Shankar. As we've heard in the previous segment, altruism is a complicated thing. It makes people feel warm and happy, but it's also driven by social pressure and public norms. On this edition of Stop-watch Science, Dan and I will present two ideas each from social science research looking at the science of generosity.
和往常一样，高级“暂停科学”记者丹·皮克加入了我的行列。嗨，丹。嗨，尚卡尔。正如我们在上一段中听到的那样，利他主义是一件复杂的事情。它让人感到温暖和快乐，但它也受到社会压力和公共规范的驱动。在本期“暂停科学”节目中，丹和我将各自从社会科学研究中提出两个观点，探讨慷慨的科学。
We get 60 seconds to present each idea, and as we approach the 60 second mark, our producers will gently bring up the music like they do at the Oscars. Dan, if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Okay, let's say you're choosing a holiday gift for a friend, and you're deciding between two video games. Now, one game is high-end and super cool, but it takes a while to learn. The other is more ordinary, it's easy to start playing, but the game is just medium quality
我们有60秒的时间来阐述每个观点，随着我们接近60秒的尾声，我们的制作人会像在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上那样，轻柔地响起音乐。丹，如果你准备好了，你的前60秒现在开始。好的，假设你正在为朋友挑选一份节日礼物，并在两个视频游戏之间做决定。现在，其中一款游戏高端且超级酷，但需要一段时间才能学会。另一款则更普通，很容易上手玩，但这款游戏只是中等质量，
and less nifty. Which gift would you rather give, and which would your friend rather receive? Now those questions are at the heart of a fascinating paper last year in the Journal of Consumer Research. Over eight experiments, researchers found that givers consistently chose desirability, special gifts, even if they're a hassle. Like that turbocharged video game
而且没那么精美。你更愿意送出哪份礼物，你的朋友又更愿意收到哪一份呢？现在，这些问题正去年发表在《消费者研究杂志》上的一篇引人入胜的论文的核心。通过八项实验，研究人员发现，赠送者始终选择令人向往的、特别的礼物，即使它们很麻烦。就像那个超频的视频游戏，
or a gift certificate to a great Italian restaurant that's an hour away. But receivers consistently valued feasibility just as much. They were equally happy with that easy to play video game, or a gift card to an okay Italian restaurant around the corner. When we sell a gift for people, we often aim for desirability. We want to pick something special, unique, unforgettable. But it turns out that the people on the receiving end, they don't much care.
或者一张距离一小时车程的优质意大利餐厅的礼品卡。但接受者始终同样看重可行性。他们对那个容易上手的视频游戏，或者转角处一家还不错的意大利餐厅的礼品卡同样感到高兴。当我们为人们挑选礼物时，我们往往追求令人向往。我们想挑选一些特别的、独特的、令人难忘的东西。但事实证明，接受礼物的人对此并不太在意。
They're just as happy with gifts that are easy, convenient, and practical. I love that, Dad, and I think this speaks to something that you've brought up before on Stopwatch Science, which is that we are often really bad at reading other people's minds. We're terrible at it, and we don't know it. So there are some workarounds that we can do. For instance, Francesca Gino, who is a friend of the show, has a great paper from a few years ago, showing that the best way to select a gift for someone is to ask them what they want rather than try to divine it
他们对那些简单、方便且实用的礼物同样感到高兴。我喜欢这样，丹，我觉得这印证了你之前在“暂停科学”中提出过的一个观点，那就是我们往往真的不擅长猜透别人的心思。我们在这方面太糟糕了，而且我们自己还不知道。所以我们可以做一些变通方法。例如，该节目的朋友弗兰切斯卡·吉诺几年前写了一篇很棒的论文，表明为某人挑选礼物的最好方法是直接问他们想要什么，而不是试图通过心灵感应去猜测。
through telepathy. All right, I get the message, Dan. What do you want for Christmas? Oh, let's see. Well, actually, my coffee maker broke, so I really just, I actually need a coffee maker pretty badly, and not a fancy one with special little valves and things that steam and word things around, just a regular working man's coffee maker.
好吧，我明白了，丹。你圣诞节想要什么？哦，让我想想。嗯，实际上，我的咖啡机坏了，所以我真的很需要一个咖啡机，而且不是那种带有特殊小阀门以及会冒蒸汽和发出嗡嗡声的花哨机器，只要一个普通打工人用的咖啡机就行。
All right, consider that done. All right, Shankar, your 60 seconds starts right now. Many of us think that learning a musical instrument or becoming a gymnast are skills that can be learned or improved with practice. But we don't think of generosity and altruism the same way. We don't think of compassion as a skill when in fact there's evidence that you can train yourself to be more compassionate. Helen Wang and Richard Davidson at the University of Wisconsin at Madison, along with other researchers, they trained volunteers to think kindly about others, to cultivate compassion
好的，这个包在我身上。好的，尚卡尔，你的60秒现在开始。我们许多人认为，学习乐器或成为体操运动员是可以通过练习来学习或提高的技能。但我们并不以同样的方式看待慷慨和利他主义。我们不认为同情心是一种技能，而事实上，有证据表明你可以通过训练让自己变得更有同情心。威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的海伦·王和理查德·戴维森，与其他研究人员一起，训练志愿者对他人抱持善意，培养同情心，
both for loved ones as well as for strangers. They find in a study published in the Journal of Psychological Science that when you do this for 30 minutes a day for two weeks, volunteers become more likely to act compassionately towards strangers who are in need of help. In other words, mental training alone can change your ability to respond to the suffering of others. They also find very interestingly, there's evidence using FMRI scanners that there are changes in the brain areas of volunteers who get the training, and these brain areas include
对挚爱以及对陌生人皆是如此。他们在《心理科学》杂志上发表的一项研究中发现，当你每天进行30分钟这样的练习，持续两周后，志愿者会更有可能对需要帮助的陌生人采取富有同情心的行动。换句话说，仅凭心理训练就能改变你对他人苦难的应对能力。他们还非常有趣地发现，使用功能性磁共振成像扫描仪的证据表明，接受训练的志愿者的脑区发生了变化，这些脑区包括
the inferior parietal cortex and the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex. It's fascinating and heartening. Martin Seligman years ago wrote a book called Learned Optimism based on his research and learn helplessness. What we're talking here is learn compassion, which would be no joke, a really great gift in the holidays. I think that's right. It's part of a larger body of work known as positive psychology, looking at how
下顶叶皮层和背外侧前额叶皮层。这真是令人着迷且备受鼓舞。马丁·塞利格曼多年前根据他对习得性无助的研究写了一本名为《学习乐观》的书。我们在这里谈论的是习得性同情心，毫不夸张地说，这将是节日里一份非常棒的礼物。我认为确实如此。这是被称为积极心理学的大型研究体系的一部分，它研究心理学如何帮助我们理解我们最好的一面，而不仅仅是最坏的一面，接下来我要把时间交给你，让你讲第二项研究。你的下一个60秒现在开始。
psychology can help us understand the best of ourselves, not just the worst of ourselves, but then I'm going to turn it over to you for your second study. Your next 60 seconds starts right now. Okay, here's a less exalted scenario, right? Someone gives me a present, say a watch. I open it and think, yeah, it's not my style. So I stick it in a new box, re-wrap it, and give it to my brother.
好的，这是一个不那么崇高的场景，对吧？有人送我一件礼物，比如一块手表。我打开它，心想，是的，这不是我的风格。所以我把它塞进一个新的盒子，重新包装，然后送给我弟弟。
It's called re-gifting. And it's offensive, right? A social taboo. Well, a set of studies by Gabrielle Adams at the London Business School says, maybe not. Adams and colleagues at Harvard and Stanford set up several experiments in which some people were gift-givers and others were gift-receivers. Then they had some of the receivers repackage their gifts and give them to someone else.
这叫做转送礼物。这很冒犯，对吧？是一个社会禁忌。好吧，伦敦商学院加布里埃尔·亚当斯的一系列研究表明，也许并非如此。亚当斯和她在哈佛及斯坦福的同事们设置了几项实验，其中一些人是礼物赠送者，另一些人是礼物接受者。然后他们让一些接受者重新包装他们的礼物并送给其他人。
Turns out, over and over again, the regifters overestimated how much the givers of the original gift would be offended. They thought the givers would be shocked, hurt, appalled by the regifting, but most givers said, hey, it's your gift now. The title is essentially passed to you. Do whatever you want. The stigma of regifting wasn't much of a stigma at all. Dan, I want to thank you for sanctioning my inner regifter.
事实证明，一次又一次地，转送礼物的人高估了最初送礼者会被冒犯的程度。他们以为送礼者会感到震惊、受伤、对转送行为感到震惊，但大多数送礼者却说：“嘿，现在这已经是你的礼物了。”所有权实际上已经转移给你了。你想怎么处理都行。转送礼物的污名其实根本算不上什么污名。丹，我要感谢你为我内心的“转送者”身份正名。
I feel completely liberated now in ways that should be very interesting to watch over the next few weeks. Oh, that's great, because I got a really special Present for you. Hi, high in desire ability, but really difficult to you So you just give it to somebody else and you'll feel better. All right now you're 60 seconds for your study Shankar starts Right now all right. This is also a study that looks at altruism except Dan It looks at the downside of altruism
我现在感到彻底解放了，这种解放的方式在接下来的几周里一定会非常有趣。哦，太棒了，因为我为你准备了一份非常特别的礼物。嗨，非常令人向往，但实际上很难使用，所以你只要把它送给别人，你就会感觉好多了。好吧，现在你关于你的研究的60秒，尚卡尔，现在开始。好的。这也是一项研究利他主义的研究，不过丹，它着眼于利他主义的阴暗面。
It's a study by friend of the show, Francesca Gino at the Harvard Business School, you just mentioned her a moment ago. Along with Shaharayal and Dan Arieli, Gino found that people are more likely to cheat when their behavior is hidden. That's not surprising. Here's the part of her study that caught my eye. When people feel that their cheating
这是该节目好友、哈佛商学院的弗兰切斯卡·吉诺的一项研究，你刚才才提到过她。她与沙哈尔·亚利和丹·艾瑞里共同发现，当人们的行为被隐藏时，他们更有可能作弊。这并不令人意外。这是她研究中吸引我眼球的部分。当人们觉得他们的作弊
can help another person, as well as themselves, cheating goes up substantially. When being dishonest can help an entire group, cheating goes up even more. What's fascinating to me here at Dan is how the hidden brain weaves together these different motives. One thing to help others is a good thing. In this case, people use a positive motive to justify being dishonest. Now I know it's the holiday season, Dan, but I'm going to make a little editorial statement
不仅能帮助自己，还能帮助另一个人时，作弊现象就会大幅上升。丹，在这里让我着迷的是，Hidden Brain是如何将这些不同的动机交织在一起的。一方面，帮助别人是一件好事。在这种情况下，人们利用一个积极的动机来为不诚实的行为辩护。现在我知道这是假日季了，丹，但我在这里要发表一点社论式的声明。
here. One of the things that many of us do is we lie to children about the existence of Santa Claus. We perpetrate this act of mass dishonesty, but we do it because we say it's in the common good. Fair point, but I just think you've totally lost our eating under-demo-grabber. All right, there you have it. Give gifts that are useful, train yourself to be more compassionate, beware of the downside of altruism and re-gift shamelessly. If you get caught, tell people Dan Pink told you to do it. Dan, thank you so much for joining us. My pleasure, I think.
我们许多人做的一件事就是对孩子们撒谎说圣诞节老人存在。我们犯下了这种大规模的不诚实行为，但我们这样做是因为我们说这是为了公共利益。很有道理，但我只是觉得你完全把我们8岁及以下的观众群体给弄丢了。好吧，事情就是这样。送出实用的礼物，训练自己变得更有同情心，当心利他主义的阴暗面，并且毫无羞耻感地转送礼物。如果你被抓包了，就告诉别人是丹·皮克让你这么做的。丹，非常感谢你加入我们。我的荣幸，我想是的。
That was Daniel Pink, our senior stopwatch science correspondent and Ace Giftgever. Can't wait to see what you got me for Christmas, Dad. We have one last segment for you this holiday. Adam Colors back to tie this episode together with a song. Adam, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Did you put in hours and hours of work to create this original song for us, Adam? Well, I put in a lot of hours listening to the episode and I put in a lot of hours listening
那是丹·皮克，我们的高级“暂停科学”记者和王牌送礼人。等不及看你圣诞节送我什么了，丹。这节日我们为你准备了最后一个环节。亚当·科尔回来了，用一首歌将这一集串联起来。亚当，欢迎回到Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我。亚当，你是不是花了好几个小时来为我们创作这首原创歌曲？嗯，我花了很多时间听这一集节目，我还花了很多时间听
to holiday music to get inspiration since this is a holiday episode. So yeah, put together a little piece sort of inspired by those really cheesy Christmas specials in which children dance around in brightly colored sweaters. Wonderful. And did you do this all by yourself yourself Adam? What did you have help? Well, you know, I actually got some help from your producer Maggie Penman. She sings on this song. Oh cool. And there's also a special guest appearance by someone you said doesn't exist.
假日音乐来寻找灵感，因为这是一期假日节目。所以是的，拼凑出了一小段作品，灵感有点类似于那些穿着色彩鲜艳毛衣的孩子们四处跳舞的、非常俗气的圣诞特辑。太棒了。亚当，这是你自己一个人完成的吗？还是有人帮忙？嗯，你知道的，我实际上得到了你们的制作人玛吉·彭曼的帮助。她在这首歌里献声了。哦，太酷了。还有一个由你曾说并不存在的人带来的特别客串演出。
I can't wait to hear this. The chestnuts are roasting and shunker stopped hosting so he could go out and sled. And Shanker stopped hosting, so he could go out and sled. There's jingle bells belling, and our hearts are swelling, And Dan pink is yelling about something he read. We're full of Christmas cheer, but let's make one thing very clear. It gives you give her thoughtful. But they're also often awful. Just give us what we asked for this year.
我迫不及待想听听这个了。栗子在烘烤，尚卡尔停止了主持，好让他能出去玩雪橇。而尚卡尔停止了主持，好让他能出去玩雪橇。铃儿响叮当，我们的心在膨胀，丹·皮克正大声嚷嚷着他读到的一些东西。我们充满了圣诞的欢乐，但让我们把一件事搞清楚。你送的礼物确实很贴心。但它们往往也很糟糕。今年就给我们想要的东西吧。
No, it's not so machine, they're hard to clean. No vibes are dinner in for me. But we'll take your coffee maker and a piece of pizza down the street. If we open a gift and we don't like what we find, we'll just re-gift it. You won't mind, but it would be terrific if you gave us the specific things that we asked for in this Christmas time. No hold on a minute. Santa Claus? Yes it's me and I'm here to tell you you're terrible. This isn't the season of receiving, it's the season of altruism.
不，这并不那么机器化，它们很难清理。对我来说没有晚餐的氛围。但我们会收下你的咖啡机和街头的一片披萨。如果我们打开礼物却不喜欢发现的东西，我们就会把它转送出去。你不会介意的，但如果你能给我们今年圣诞节我们要求的具体东西，那就太棒了。不，等一下。圣诞老人？是的，是我，我是来告诉你你们太糟糕了。这不是接受的季节，这是利他主义的季节。
Altruism? Sounds lame Santa. Yeah, what do you know? You're just an act of vastness honesty You perpetrate annually for the sake of children. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no Pole. I was a mean old elf, no! Just like the Grinch, my heart, it was pinched, and I only thought of myself. But then I practiced carrying, 30 minutes every day, and my torso lateral, prefrontal cortex slowly began to change.
利他主义？听起来真逊，圣诞老人。是啊，你懂什么？你只是每年为了孩子们而实施的大规模不诚实行为。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不,极。我曾经是个吝啬的老精灵，不！就像格林奇一样，我的心曾被揪紧，我只想着自己。但后来我练习关怀，每天30分钟，我的背外侧前额叶皮层慢慢开始发生变化。
I don't know Santa, practicing empathy sounds like a lot of work. No, for years, a lot of people don't practice compassion. They're only generous when they think people are watching. That's why I watch from my sleigh, both night and day. A jolly one man, NSA. So if someone for is at your door, I'll see if you turn them away. If you don't help people with their problems,
我不知道，圣诞老人，练习同情心听起来像是一项繁重的工作。不，多年来，很多人并不练习同情心。他们只有在认为有人在看着他们时才表现得慷慨。这就是为什么我在雪橇上日夜监视。一个快乐的独行国家安全局。所以如果有人在你的门口，我会看看你是否把他们拒之门外。如果你不帮别人解决问题，
you'll make my list, and not the nice color. It's my duty and my pleasure to apply the social pressure So people will be selfless to squeeze Fast high Doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh doh do Merry Christmas, Mrs. Ders! No! Ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho- That's right, I'm glad that you are a big, enough man to admit that. Adam, thank you so much for joining me. Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Karamakar Kalasin and Maggie Penman, our new assistant is Max Nestra, special thanks this week to Daniel Pink and Adam Cole. For more Hidden Brain, follow us on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram. Our weekly newsletter gives you lots of valuable tips.
你会进入我的名单，而且不是好孩子名单。应用社会压力是我的职责也是我的荣幸，这样人们就会无私地去挤压……圣诞快乐，德尔斯夫人！不！没错，我很高兴你是个有担当、承认这一点的男子汉。亚当，非常感谢你加入我。谢谢邀请我。Hidden Brain由卡拉玛卡·卡拉辛和玛吉·彭曼制作，我们的新助理是马克斯·内斯特拉克，本周特别感谢丹·皮克和亚当·科尔。想收听更多Hidden Brain节目，请在推特、脸书和Instagram上关注我们。我们的每周简报为您提供许多宝贵的建议。
Send an email to hiddenbrainatnpr.org with the word subscribe in the subject line. I'm Shankar Vedantun and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
发送电子邮件至hiddenbrain@npr.org，并在主题行中写上“subscribe”一词。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。